sur la scène canadienne c'est la
huitième semaine de campagne électorale
qui commence aujourd'hui et le rythme ne
ralentit pas alors denis fabre ont
d'abord dû chef libéral qui se garde une
marge de manoeuvre à au sujet de son
cadre financier qui me promet de rendre
public d'ici la fin de la campagne et ça
va sûrement alimenter les discussions
ce qu'il dit c'est qu'il maintient
évidemment l'engagement de revenir à
l'équilibré budgétaire en 2019 c'est
toujours le plein ce qui ne précise pas
quand on lui parle de flexibilité c'est
advenant des imprévus s'il va jouer
autant sur les dépenses que les revenus
par exemple sur certains de ses
engagements qu'il pourrait retarder
il n'est pas précis là-dessus ce qu'on
comprend cependant c'est que le déficit
pourrait varier
écoutez son explication est ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui ce que à les déficits
modeste ça va être pour les trois
premières années on a aussi dit si la
situation s'empire est de façon radicale
on reviendrait peut-être ces chiffres là
à mais pour l'instant on est on était
très très conservateur dans le bon sens
dans notre évaluation des chiffres et
nous sommes on a été très prudent dans
l'évaluation de nos chiffres et j'ai
confiance dans notre plan et notre cadre
fiscal que vous allez voir
au cours de la campagne se défendre au
sujet de ses déclarations sur les f 35
oui parce que lui ce qu'il ferait
premièrement c'est annulé le contrat ou
qui n'existe pas mais l'éliminerait
disons le recours éventuel wef 35 ce
qu'il en serait plutôt lui c'est un
appel d'offres pour les concurrents
actuels du f-35 les concurrents connus
dont les appareils répondent un peu
davantage selon lui aux besoins du
canada
et troisièmement il prendrait les
dollars économisés et les dépenses est
du côté de la marine canadien ces
adversaires là dessus sur cette base là
re met carrément en question les
compétences du chef libéral et
l'annoncent la perte des contrats dans
la saq le secteur aérospatial de
montréal et il annonce et il semble de
ne pas comprendre que la chose la plus
important pour le secteur manufacturier
et du canard est que le goudron du
canada faire c'est nos propres
investissements et investissements non
notre notre approvisionnement ministre
avait vu times michael et et à dartmouth
en nouvelle-écosse où il courtise une
clientèle qu'il ait beaucoup courtisé
pendant la campagne et les anciens
combattants près d'un demi milliard de
plus sur quatre ans pour régler les
problèmes de stress post traumatique 2
sentimentale d'accès aux soins de longue
durée et aussi la réouverture des neuf
bureaux de service les genoux que le
gouvernement harper a fermé
voilà merci aux coûts des différents au
revoir